si se abre la subrayo estaría en segunda
vuelta así lo aseguró el candidato ya
cooper es candidato presidencial por el
movimiento político indígena pachakuti
que insiste en el fraude electoral ahora
junto a 22 organizaciones sociales que
se han manifestado públicamente en
apoyar sus peticiones por segunda
ocasión una movilización se dirige al
consejo nacional electoral para mantener
una vigilia indefinida porque se abran
las urnas y se realice el conteo total
ahora del 100 por ciento de las actas
partiendo desde aquí es el parque el
arbolito en la ciudad de quito al
consejo nacional electoral para que
demuestra la transparencia la honestidad
que el pueblo ecuatoriano pide gane
quien gane
queremos que respete esa democracia y
hoy empezamos una serie de acciones de
movilización y en el plano jurídico para
que se respete el resultado del 7 de
febrero en medio de las movilizaciones
rechazaron el conteo del 30 por ciento
de las actas revisados sin la presencia
representante del movimiento político
indígena pachakuti asegura que como la
segunda fuerza electoral del parlamento
buscará
juicio a la oposición al consejo
nacional electoral
pedimos al contencioso electoral
procedan con la destitución definitiva
del actual consejo nacional electoral
este viernes concluirá el plazo que le
otorga la ley al consejo nacional
electoral para pronunciarse ante las
peticiones presentadas de producirse una
respuesta negativa a las peticiones y ya
qu pérez impugnarán nuevamente los
resultados ante el tribunal contencioso
electoral paralelamente los candidatos
andrés grau y guillermo lasso se apuran
a realizar actividades de promoción que
no están reguladas por el órgano rector
antes de comenzar la campaña de segunda
vuelta el 16 de marzo